avec la crise sanitaire les
organisateurs de colonies de vacances
redoutent le pire certaines structures
créées de même de ne pas pouvoir s'en
relever
car depuis quelques années déjà l'écolo
attire moins en 2019 seulement 25% des
enfants de 7 à 12 ans avait déjà
séjourné en colonie bien loin de l'âge
d'or retour dans les années 60
16h30 allons debout c'est l'heure pour
certains le réveil est un peu dur à
cette époque les colonies de vacances
attire chaque année quatre millions
d'enfants contre 1,4 millions en 2019
des centres gérés par les communes par
les comités d'entreprise avec un but de
la mixité sociale et de l'autonomie pour
les enfants chacun de son côté l'on part
pour la toilette l'ardeur ne mentent pas
sinon l'expérience pas trop de chichis
pas d'activité extraordinaire mais du
grand air et des copains une opération
gabbana été organisées aussi garçons et
filles s'affairent à faire de leur
cabane la plus belle mais dès les années
80 le visage des colonies change des
stages à thème
équitation astronomie séjour à
l'étranger et les prix sans flamme que
deviennent les jolies colonies dans les
années 60 4 millions d'enfants six
rondes et aujourd'hui ils ne sont plus
qu'un million que s'est il passé
je crois qu'il ya un problème de prix
des prix qui deviennent de plus en plus
élevés aujourd'hui le coût moyen d'un
séjour en colonie est de 800 euros
le brassage social essence même des
colonies n'est plus vraiment d'actualité
alors certains militent pour renforcer
les aides financières allouées afin de
permettre au plus grand nombre de goûter
aux joies des colos la mixité sociale
elle est permise par les financeurs
aujourd'hui on a besoin des
collectivités des comités d'entreprise
des allocations de la caf pour permettre
le départ en vacances car aujourd'hui en
france trois millions d'enfants ne
partent pas en vacances
les colonies serait donc un moyen de
combattre cette inégalité
[Musique]